[Music]
this is the Lord Howe Island stick
insect and this species did the
impossible
they came back from extinction the Lord
Howe Island stick insect is the largest
flightless stick insect and can grow up
to four inches in length that's almost
the length of an adult humans hand it is
affectionately nicknamed the tree
lobster the land lobster and even the
walking sausage Lord Howe Island stick
insects were once so common on Lord Howe
Island that they were used as bait by
fishermen then a British supply ship
crashed on the island in 1918
accidentally introducing rats who ate
the insects by 1960 they were declared
extinct then in 2001 Australian
scientists discovered a tiny population
hidden on a small volcanic island nearby
thanks to a breeding program at
Melbourne Zoo they have been able to
save and repopulate this species this is
the Lord Howe Island stick insect
[Music]
this is the Hercules beetle one of the
largest insects on earth
[Music]
the Hercules beetle is named for its
incredible strength it can lift and
carry loads 850 times heavier than its
own weight the most distinguishing
characteristic of the Hercules beetle is
the horn like pincers on its head only
male beetles have this intimidating
feature and it is used as a formidable
weapon in the battle for mating rights
the horns are usually about a third of
their body length but have been known to
grow even longer
Hercules beetles are found in Central
and South America and in the West Indies
and feed predominantly on rotting wood
as larvae and fruit as adults in spite
of its strength and size the Hercules
beetle is a threatened species in many
countries much of its natural habitat
has been lost to deforestation
and its populations are suffering this
is the Hercules beetle
[Music]
this is the black beauty stick insect a
rare bug found only in a tiny 12 acre
area high in the remote mountains of
northern Peru
discovered in 2005 the black beauty
stick insect has a velvet black body
covered in small bristles the only other
colors on its body are its piercing
golden yellow eyes and it's bright red
wings not much is known about their
species but scientists have observed it
to be most active at night when its deep
black coloration keeps it hidden from
predators in addition to its powerful
nighttime camouflage the black beauty
stick insect is armed with a gland at
the rear of its head and when threatened
can spray a coercive strong smelling
substance at its attacker because their
natural habitat is so small the black
beauty stick insect survival is
precarious and because of its striking
features they have become a popular
insect in the pet trade
luckily due to successful captive
breeding efforts this particular threat
may be on the decline this is the black
beauty stick insect
[Music]
you
[Music]
this is the red need tarantula she's got
quite the outfit
unfortunately her striking features have
made her a hot commodity in the illegal
pet trade found in the forests of
southwestern Mexico red needs are some
of the largest spiders growing up to
eight inches in size besides size they
beautiful red white black and orange has
are what separates them from other
spiders the hairs on their legs are used
to sense vibrations from predators and
prey they prey on large insects frogs
and mice biting and injecting them with
their venom their alluring look has made
them the most popular captive tarantula
causing a major population to climb
today regulations are in place requiring
permits to remove any of these beauties
from the wild this is the red knee
tarantula
[Music]
named for its method of burying rotting
carcasses to feed its young this is the
gravedigger of the animal kingdom the
American burying beetle
these beetles feed on small decomposing
animals like birds and mice inside there
on 10 a are strong chemical receptors
that detect rushing meat they have
powerful wings and will travel long
distances to reach their meal males and
females work together to bury the corpse
and females will then lay her eggs
nearby after the larvae hatch both
parents tend to their young a behavior
rarely found in insects once a prolific
Beetle found in over 35 states across
the u.s. today it can be found in just 6
listed as endangered back in 1989 the
American burying beetles future is bleak
while conservation efforts are underway
there is still a long way to go this is
the American burying beetle utilising
one of the most efficient natural
camouflages on earth this is the pink
winged stick insect
[Music]
true to its name the pink winged stick
insect does resemble a stick they have
been observed making repetitive side to
side movements mimicking a stick blowing
in the wind as camouflage is their
biggest defense many stick insects are
nocturnal and in the face of an attack
will play dead some have been seen to
even shed a limb to evade a predator
long and thin these insects range
between 13 and 21 inches in length with
females being longer than the males
little is known about stick insects
making it difficult to declare the
vulnerability of their status in the
wild however this one is endemic to
madagascar and was listed as an
endangered species due to aggressive
deforestation in the area this is the
pink winged stick insect okay I'm Lois
and I'm Charlie and we have been told
and we believe that we have the largest
private collection of insects in the
world yeah
[Music]
the story of how we met was interesting
enough I was a teaching assistant at the
University of Arizona and Lois was a
student in the class that I was teaching
we've been married for almost 55 years
he's got a million stories about insects
all of which I've heard and all of which
I can fill in sentences and we've
traveled extensively have been to all
the continents and 70 countries
collecting it fills us with pleasure to
get into the field and collect to spend
the time in the field together oh you
need to look at the antenna on one of
these it looks like a clown shoe well I
study weevils and the weevils are the
largest family of living organisms these
are plant hoppers and I think their
noses are too
I collect plant hoppers which are
insects that feed on the juices of
plants the phone or the xylem with
piercing sucking mouthparts
with piercing sucking mouthparts oh yeah
when when we get some insects in they're
just dead of course we have to mount
them so we have to pin them or point
them and then we label um ah the blue is
not stiff enough and he's falling off
his point then after I do that then I
sort him to genus each of these units
trays holds 55 specimens on average and
we have at least a million weevils and a
quarter of a million flying hours
okay here you come darling we are
donating the collection to Arizona State
University and there will be research
done on it which is what we wanted to
have happen when we were entomologists
at the university we worked 14 hours a
day seven days a week now we're down to
eight to ten hours a day seven days a
week it's a lot of work but we both
loved what we were doing and it was
sharing that it was part of our life
yeah which one do you think is the
prettiest these two I don't like that
one Louis is often taken note of the
fact that a very large number of
entomologists are divorced what I
recommend is if you're going to be a
taxon unless estimate us collect insects
you get a spouse it is another
entomologist
[Music]